previously on the forest happy birthday
trap
happy birthday i'm curious if i'll take
any damage to you i will
oh my god all right
thanks wade you said the wrong way last
time i sat the right way when i went to
get up i lit myself on fire
myself preservation right very high so i
will not be running through that door
ever again
do you actually live on fire again
myself preservation stick sucks
whoa jesus man is that aimed at me
ow wait i can drink water from this
little pond
oh it's not oh guys i'm dying
are you actually dead oh my god
anyway i want to try to slingshot one of
these dudes because i want their bones
i'm going to destroy these dudes
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah very bush out
here
sure
oh you dead oh i killed him man dude
slingshot does
so much damage did you just absolutely
wreck some news dude well just you wait
one second i have a gift i see our base
wait i've got some delicious food over
here for you don't worry about it
let me tell you about delicious
food i have just absolutely
made a banger of a weapon i was
a tenth of a step away from going
through the [ __ ] dream
guys close your eyes i got a present oh
no oh no wait mark
look mark i got food oh that is wrong
no oh no this is a club you can totes
have it if you want it i'm okay
oh no no no don't ask how i got the
human skull it's uh
as long as you don't ask how i got the
chieftain here i i
like just don't don't ask questions you
straight murder that dude dude
slingshot is death that's nice oh my god
i have dynamite
why do you have to die you want
something you want some dynamite
give me what i want what do you want i
don't know man you better figure it out
i don't know what what do you want what
if i just what if i just
casually hit l on this bad boy casually
hit l
is this what you want uh yeah
that's okay that's kind of doing it okay
okay okay okay
no i lost all of my armor that dude had
a lot of
arms yeah you know oh his head came off
his arm came off armor is not
recoverable on death at all oh
no is that what you wanted uh i don't
know mark
is it what i wanted that's the most
threatening thing i can do mark look at
this
oh my god what's wrong with you
oh no way to go wait a minute wait
where'd it go it's missing
what do you mean i lost the stick of
dynamite
i threw it now it's gone everyone turn
on your lighters and look real close
everyone hold your lighter up and
scrounge around for the dynamite
no i don't see them oh here it's over
here it's over here okay good okay good
well that's
mystery you have a club man i have a
club
too mine's a little more deluxe
yeah once you get the collector's
edition jesus
costs a little more but you know it's
worth it in the long run that's cool
that's
cool dude head use on fire you should
definitely see what happens if you do
that
i think that's what you want i think
it's what you want i think it's okay i'm
gonna use head on fire
what is this well this is our explosive
this is where the dynamite lives
so make sure if you're gonna have your
lighter out you get real close to the
dynamite with your lighter
i put my molotov on the first shell oh
you have a molotov look at you dude
there's many body parts on this fire i
would not recommend eating them
also what do i do with this corpse which
one this one i brought in here should i
chuck it outside yeah it might affect
our sanity meters if you leave it in all
right okay okay
yeah our sanity is important here put it
by the sos so they know we mean business
ah should we uh should we doze oh you
always want a doze you never wanna just
look at the stars
there's a few up there they're great now
you want to sleep you want to sleep why
do you want to sleep man what's wrong
with you i'm going to get a popsicle you
think about what's wrong with you
guys apparently skull lamps are the meta
because apparently skull lamps never go
out and don't need fuel
oh i've got some skulls i'm not 100
sure how i'm sculling us up oh
what happened to uh oh mark you're
you're screwing these old things
this lamp sucks uh where's that body you
had where the body that's the body of
the fire look
you're close to your bone throne what do
you mean bone oh
bone all right hang on we need that body
yeah go toss the whole body right here
don't boss me around hey it's on fire
we're really making this place a home
yeah dude skull lamps
dude legs roasted on the open fire wait
you can eat the legs the legs didn't
cook down the bone now the legs is
edible
well i'm real hungry so i'm gonna see
what happens if i eat the leg you know
what
hey mmm this is good this guy you can't
stop this guy
delicious long pork no negative side
effects for that huh totally fine
and i don't want to kill you then the
least bit weird about it as a person my
health i didn't have much of dropped so
i think
it didn't i didn't drop i don't think so
i just watched it
i don't think that's right i feel
stronger if anything nature god
there's boars in this island oh my god
we got so many extra bluebee
seeds crocodiles think i didn't run into
those while i was where are crocodiles
in this place
what is that a photo of that is
inappropriate that's what that is
what are you looking at i found a
picture of some kind of
man if i look at your journal right now
your glasses were perfectly
all right it's gone this is fantastic
bob you seeing what i'm singing
no i'm out here doing work making bank
what are you what are you seeing oh
there it is
your face for some reason is shadowed
onto your book
and it just says for timmy what's up bob
you need something
no i'm just doing work we really need
sticks i'll go take a look that'd be a
lot easier to look around for stuff if
you knew we
slept the night away while i was waiting
to sleep and everyone else was messing
around so now i'm doing this
i'll sleep i'll sleep now you'll sleep
strong it's good sleep i like sleep
dude this is uh that's a fun game living
like kings here
at some point i know we're going to be
attacked but it just hasn't happened yet
yeah i mean this is supposed to be hard
mode too
let's try some of this dried meat here
oh delicious
delightful even yeah that's good stuff
scrumptious
my dude how do you assign something to a
hot bar
combine the item with your bag for the
hot bar oh
bag yeah combine it with oh [ __ ] oh
huh god dang it
ah okay okay okay okay i drank all my
booze because i'm an
idiot i'm just gonna put all my weapons
on the hot bar so i don't accidentally
consume
[ __ ] anymore yeah it's a good idea i'm
gonna go hunt some more
cannibals oh i equipped a pouch
guys two rabbit pelts is a pouch which
increases my inventory maybe
no way bruh i don't know what that did
but i very dramatically
quit wait can i fill this with water
what does this do
i'm holding the pouch it looks like it
would hold water
you can make a water skin out of to deer
skin
i have a water skin oh i think i have
two deer skin on me
what does my pouch do though how do you
make more rope a cloth
used to collect berries the pouch
collects berries bro
you can have a whole pouch of berries
bro oh
[ __ ] how do you guys get a rabbit just
lucky slam just yeah just whack it
i if you trap it against something
they're pretty dumb so it's easy to just
get it stuck and then hit it
oh hey bud where are you going bud
are you where are you hey bud oh oh
he did uh i got another dead dude and i
got another super good cl i can't carry
more good club
wait this is a non-bad guy camp there's
tents over here bro
what there's tents no way
with cots no way
i just smashed their basket for no
reason because i'm an [ __ ]
oh it's an ambush a good idea
a bad ambush a bad one define a good one
mark i need your slingshot where are you
at buddy i'm trying to get this lizard
ah
it's juking me how do you see what what
armor you have on you uh the around your
health bar there's a bunch of little
tiny bars
and that shows you how many pieces you
have
mark uh how far are you you're pretty
far yeah what's up i've got a whole
bunch of bad
bad baddies surrounding me i love that
for you
i could just really use a good sling so
good
for you yeah i'm actually yeah i'm out
of tiny rocks
this is really unfortunate i wish my
water skin could
collect water when it's raining yeah
that'd be nice let me see if i can get
my water skin to like
draw from the river maybe i'll found him
again hey friends howdy howdy how are
you
back where are you at where are you i'm
coming back to camp i was chasing a
rabbit and ended up in hell twice
i don't think you'd be able to to get
water out of the river with my water
skin
me neither this river sucks all right
i'm over here what do you need doing
uh there's some bad guys up the hill oh
hey you're up there
yeah i'm looking around well this case
is uh
this is filled with potential
okay it's gone is it no longer filled
with potential
it was uh it was really moving and then
it went into another universe so i'm not
100 sure
a lot of cloth on these lines yeah they
got
mad claws are you [ __ ] me yeah oh
you little [ __ ] bunny rabbit i will
[ __ ] your day
look man why don't you just be nice by
stabbing it in the face with the spear
yeah we're asked nicely to do said
action dear rabbit may i please murder
the [ __ ] out of you so i can have a
berry pouch
i have so much cloth here oh my god it's
the mega totem
oh also i found a cave entrance here yo
you're timmy uh
your timmy uh might be down in one of
these caves i'm thinking
nah i mean maybe but like who cares
oh okay come here i need to kill
something dude relatable am i right
fun drink i'm having a horrible time out
here
i'm up here with you what is wrong with
you i can't kill anything
you can throw your spears by the way but
i um also missed the rabbit that way
you know i've stolen pretty much
everything around this camp i haven't
seen anybody come by
well i'm kind of accidentally working my
way over towards you bros so
yeah i'm at the ship oh wait that's
right isn't there a front half of this
uh the the plane that we're supposed to
find with like navigation radio and
stuff like that
i've never played this game before but
sure yeah probably i think there's a
front half
somewhere okay
are you dunking on noobs or something i
got it
so yes okay i'm coming to you bob do you
see any action over there that's fun
no i just crafted myself a little slingo
i just need lizards
oh wait oh no you know what how i was
saying no action the guy literally just
came running up and was like
how many times you gotta hit these
a-holes before they die mark uh with a
slingshot like twice
i have hit this dude six times now he's
not dying
well i'm coming to help it depends okay
i got a badass club i'm pretty sure he
don't stand a chance
he did bro okay are you dead bro man
these guys are no
you put this on hard right yeah this is
supposed to be hard
what a bunch of chumps i'm going to make
a suggestion
once once i get back we since we're all
loaded up with armor
we got some good weapons we go into a
cave
we get into their home base beat the
snot out of them
and then if timmy happens to be there
maybe rescue timmy
maybe leave him for dead i don't protest
about our armor situation because wadi
lost it all so uh
so full up on armor i am one slot away
from full armor
i have zero well one
armor piece sounds like weighty needs to
be
uh haunting some lizards yeah yeah it
sounds like to me
you do what do you do how much water
does this
bastard hold are you kidding me how are
you feeling it i'm filling it from the
water collecticles
i just emptied all three of them into my
water skin greedy
all right you you guys ready to cruise
into the
heart of the
i got the deluxe though you got the
deluxe oh oh hell yeah yeah dude i got a
i got the
upgrade we're all right full armor
deluxe i have nothing this is going
great
oh you get a lot of bones when you cook
an entire human
bone armor am i wearing bone armor can
you guys see my
bones i don't know am i wearing bone
armor
can you see my bones oh it's on your
face
oh it's on your face dude wait we are
bone armor bro i've gotten zero bones
and zero lizards
boned up why are you what have you been
doing stop branching your spirit me dude
hunting
rabbits can i have a bone or a lizard
i'm gonna actually
freshen up a bone fresh out man
tell you what though i have one deer
skin for you if you want that
oh yes please oh you can make a stick
bag and a rock bag
those would be incredibly useful shall
we sleep
and then tomorrow we bring battle to our
enemies
yeah yeah tomorrow i will be there and i
will be ready
we can't sleep actually it's apparently
our sleepy meter is not ready
oh save though well i definitely saved
i'm cold and wet
bro trust me the fire situation is
handled
apparently this is my seat sorry i'm
afraid of sitting down anyway wow
look we may have been total strangers
when we crashed here
but i'm happy to say that you two are
like my
greatest friends agree we're all
brothers here
all three of us yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh
you nod like this you know that you said
yeah you were shaking your head no
the storm's really kicking up huh here
let's go let's be productive i'm going
to bring some
sticks back okay i'm dying of cold i
guess this is a goal plan
nah it's probably fine what a sound
somebody out there knows about sounds
you hearing things
they're making some real bangers
oh my god oh they're here uh
that was weird that you did that right
as i put a leaf on the fire what do you
mean what do you mean
they're here i think you went to where
they are where are you i thought you
both were out here
well i didn't go that far away you know
what i do
singing stick songs oh yeah then we came
back together
okay uh they're somewhere out oh they're
afraid of this river they won't cross it
i got my slingshot bro let's get him
what is how do you have such a bright
light i need their bodies
knocked a tooth out damn okay the club
doesn't do as much damage as i thought
it would
knock another tooth out oh oh now
oh they're going behind us he's down
she's down help wade
got him i got this one beer okay i got i
got her i'm gonna take her we're gonna
have more bone armor for wade
it's gonna get bony make sure you get
one more of those i think you only get
four bones per body
you all right wood oh yeah yeah i just
wanted that body i lost my spears i was
trying to equip a weapon so
there's one right here all right i got a
body
so maybe we can get weight some bone
armor i guess i'm trying
lunk yeah paparon get the bonfire going
dude they really they really burn yeah
they do these bodies very flammable
bones hey wait bones on the ground i
like bones bones are good for me
i like bones give them all to me
a cool song dude thank you i call it the
bone song
oh you got a little shin guard look at
you oh look at weights look at where it
is
yeah you protect that shin yeah you keep
that shin safe
you are so protected right now dude yeah
aren't i he shuffles away happily
i am protected all right bedtime guys
yeah let's sleep it off all right
so we just need to find a cave entrance
and then go in the cave
and then kill everything in there are
you guys ready
do we know where the cave entrance is or
are we finding the cave entrance up in
here
getting a few riley what there's got to
be a cave rancher around river tomorrow
i know what you're saying where did the
mark go all right
i'm looking going off in the direction
that you all
is this the weird drowning lake i'm not
touching this lake yeah if there's a
little pond over there don't do that
yeah that's that's not no touchy don't
do it do it
oh okay i heard you loud
no there's so many there's like five of
them what do you mean
where did they come from
there's plenty of bones that's for sure
mark you seeing this
i see oh they're inching closer all
right i'm circling with
four of them here mark please help help
me i beat you almost here
please how did you beat me i think
they're scared of me do we have a mutual
respect for me
no no i don't think so no oh man they
flank fast
oh boy i'll tell you what
they really go all in on that flank yeah
well that was the swing of the mist out
there goes all my armor
i've weakened out i need to get my
stamina back up
bigger than the other yeah oh one of
them
murders you if he touches you whoa good
night
oh wait down it's fine oh
my he's very big wait you have the big
one
he's right here one of them is following
me and really
douching me yeah this one's really
optioned up i'm out of stamina
i'm out of stamina can i get you up can
i get you up can i i cannot oh god i'm
gonna get you up i'm gonna get you up
i gotta go i'll get across
oh my god oh no i am literally
the tiniest little sliver of health i'm
rivering might be safe in the water
i'm i'm rivering right now
are we safe ken are we safe out here
mark you are kicking his ass yeah i sure
am get right
so one's coming down the hill never mind
behind you oh not safe not safe not safe
okay i'm taking the big body because
this is a big prize right
or should i keep finishing these guys
ow oh my god ow i can't take a single
hit or i'm gonna go down look at the
body
yeah wait do you try and get out of here
with it
whoa oh goodnight i'm down again
oh oh man he jumped into the water
nice mark's over here let me see if i
can get weighed let me see if i can get
away okay
we should build a campfire on this side
of the water and burn them over here
cook them up
yeah cook them up all right i'm coming
to back you up yeah you run
you running wonk the mistake get up
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
okay yeah let's build a fire
there were more right no nothing yeah i
think some of them
fled at the fear at the absolute
water
where's the big boy where'd you put the
big one
[Laughter]
i always burned my enemies when i killed
them in combat
well we really didn't find a cave did we
but this is better guys it's better
better i really need to dry off i really
need to dry off
now is the question i have no armor i am
out
oh chad just gave me the hottest tip yet
if you need small rocks
just equip a regular stick and poke the
ground
what really what oh my god
is that working yeah oh my god wait i
don't have any sticks
can i here let me give you a stick hang
on wait would you like a stick
oh thank you sir i appreciate you you're
welcome so what do you what do you do
you just whining
on the ground on the ground yeah and i
got coins too
oh yeah some extra bones here if you
guys want some bone armor
uh keep crafting it up man i got three
pieces equipped now
wow what did what what an industry we
have here
what is this this is the silliest thing
this game is really silly sometimes i
gotta admit
i mean i did think there must be a way
to generate small rocks because like
the slingshot is useless if you can only
gather five small rocks at a time
but this is perfect it brilliant even
brilliant
okay i think the ground dries up
eventually no no i'm still getting more
there's got to be like a slingshot
quiver or something like that
there is there's a you can you can make
a small rock
bag how do you make that a skin of some
sort
i don't have any skins at the moment
interesting we still got a few people up
here running around scampering
oh we should murder the [ __ ] out of them
i don't have any
there's more coming over here i've got a
four i've got four over here
oh where's over here we engaging this we
do bob i got i got like
holy [ __ ] you got a whole field of them
mark we need your help
okay be right there what about you right
above you on the hill
there's yeah mark we um oh yeah okay
nope nope
this this slingshot seems to do less
damage than it used to
what happened something happened that
they all sprinted okay it's fine
all right got one bloody
whoa man these guys are on good drugs
mark one of them's coming for you i
think you're one of them
dealing with one of them it's dead i'm
bringing it to the fire
coming down i'll be there in a moment we
got one
i guess he's out of here okay you better
die
just i gotta bring this body over to the
body fire you better die
if someone if someone killed all my
friends and then as i was running for my
life they were like you better
die i'd be terrified that would honestly
be the scariest thing
i like this is this the game now we just
murder as many people as we can find
and we never have armor because they
always get cheap shots in
no this dude's going down bro
your worst nightmare is here ow
freaking oh my god he almost one-shot me
he's kind of tough he freaking rage
dude yeah that guy's i think he's i mean
he's like with family
oh jesus that burned through all of my
health
literally oh his brother his bro is
coming
oh don't you bro dude he's so
fast mark let's get him i'm going to as
soon as my stamina comes back up come on
get him
wow he's fast holy [ __ ] he's gone
not even close all right yeah maybe we
should just lick our wounds and uh take
these bones back to base
i'm gonna lube up my weapon get it i
really
lubed it we got so many teeth i didn't
realize closing their teeth
yeah dude teeth it up you know if you
put teeth and
lube on your weapon it goes faster
no it goes slower but damage goes
through the roof
oh i thought it went faster i thought
teeth plus lube equals
speed feather plus lube equals speed
oh slippy feathers yeah i know that okay
that's my bad that's my bad that's my
bad all right uh i
i will have to say i'm probably gonna be
tapping out oh yeah [ __ ] it's five
o'clock
good what about our cave we'll have to
get it next time bro
oh oh that sounds good
[Music]